pouvez vous me décrire sa forme non
commencer par le début
[Musique]
tu crois que je vais pouvoir quand tu
t'en vas tu crois que je reste dans le
jardin planté là les yeux rivés au ciel
pourquoi t'es pas côté je dois partir un
jour plus tôt
votre mari est ici laissez moi le voir
il est gravement malade vous devez me
dire où il était ce qu'il faisait
c'est lui qui a décidé d'y entrer
c'est une chose qu'ils appellent le
miroitement on a envoyé des drones des
groupes de gens mais rien ne revient
jamais un homme réussit nous est
biologiste vous avez été militaire si je
savais ce qui lui est arrivé pour il
celui la frontière s'élargit le
phénomène s'étend on parle de vie
entière d'état vous voulez savoir ce
qu'il y à l'intérieur aussi
c'est splendide regarder ça diraient
qu'elles sont en constante mutation rien
d'intéressant là dedans
non les requins ont ce genre de danse
est pas possible on peut pas croiser
deux espèces différentes
c'est quoi les soldats de la dernière
expédition ils sont devenus fous ou bien
quelque chose d à tuer s'est passé à
travers le grillage à travers le
grillage rentrer à la base je ne
rentrerai pas
on campe ici cette nuit
c'est en train de tout détruire
ça ne détruit pas
fais quelque chose de nouveau
[Musique]